these Mexicans have taken the law into
their own hands they say they can't rely
on the police to defend their
communities against drug gangs oh yes it
was there were kidnappings daily three
four five a day
normal people were being killed this is
a small town near the resort of Acapulco
bana a photojournalist
once to show us how the cartels are
undermining law and order in the whole
region then there's commotion gangs are
reported nearby and the vigilantes set
off it's not safe to go alone
there could be clashes it's better to
wait here just a few days earlier banner
found himself in the crossfire his
colleague was shot and bled to death on
the seat of the car that we're using
today death is constantly on banners
mind
the stranglehold of the cartels has
changed the face of Acapulco the resort
was once a paradise of the Jet Set but
now thousands of tourists have canceled
their trips because every day the city
is the scene of brutal killings even on
the famous beachfront prior to being
murdered victims faced torture the
terrorists caused people to fall silent
those who do speak out are killed and
endanger their families it breaks my
heart to see children and pregnant women
being killed but what can I do nothing
abandoned police stations the gangs have
literally scared them away with gunfire
the police are outgunned by the thugs
they often receive no salaries the money
is funneled to politicians instead an
officer tells us anonymously that some
police officers go on strike while
others decide to work for the gangs
unfortunately all levels of state
security have been infiltrated all of
them we meet with some angry teachers
one of their colleagues was just shot
dead we teachers are being extorted they
kidnap us and whoever can't pay a ransom
is killed drugs human and organ
trafficking and extortion bring in
millions of euros for the cartels we
enter the neighborhood where the teacher
was murdered
a new gang has recently moved in and the
area is very dangerous only the
residents who can't leave remain a
two-year-old's was killed here in this
car two people were beaten to death
almost every corner has been the scene
of murder we have to quickly hide the
camera barriner has spotted a lookout
they are often not older than 14 and the
killers who have become increasingly
brutal are the same age
one said he's high on drugs sometimes
that's how he gouged out people's eyes
and tore the skin off their faces while
they were alive violence prevails on the
streets of Acapulco not the rule of law
it's getting dark and it's too dangerous
for us to continue filming but bear nun
doesn't allow the threat of the cartels
to prevent him from doing his work